cette question à présent au chapitre
économique combien l'état at il vraiment
mis sur la table pour sortir la france
de la crise ducobu de 19 dans cette dans
sa dernière allocution emmanuel macron
parler de 500 milliards d'euros et d'un
plan européen à venir de 750 milliards
mais au-delà de ces annonces
spectaculaires quelles sont les dépenses
réellement engagées sont elles à la
hauteur de ces chiffres qui marquent les
esprits
on voit cela a tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en duplex
avec nos bons soirs jacques merci d'être
avec nous bonsoir vous ne semblez pas
croire le président de la république
quand il annonce que 500 milliards ont
été engagés pour la relance pour quelle
raison ce scepticisme alors il ne s'agit
pas d'accuser ici emmanuel macron
d'avoir voulu propager des défaites news
mais il est très clair qu'il a au
minimum confondues les torchons et les
serviettes et c'est encore plus vrai si
on regarde ce qu'il dit non seulement
sur les actions du gouvernement français
mais aussi sur les actions de la
commission européenne
donc je vous propose de voir ça un petit
peu on détaille comment sont justement
par les mesures de soutien que voulez
vous dire avec mélanger les torchons et
les serviettes d'écouté c'est très
simple stéphanie vous prenez les mesures
qui ont été annoncées les mesures de
soutien qui ont été annoncées à
différentes activités ou des grands
secteurs de l'économie
eh bien vous voyez que dans la le projet
de loi de finances rectificative qui a
été déposée le 10 juin dernier
il ya absolument nous aucune mention qui
est fait d'un chiffre de 500 milliards
les chiffres que l'on trouve et qui sont
pas négligeables par ailleurs un
avoisine à peu de choses près à 43
milliards alors oui ce n'est pas
négligeable mais c'est 43 milliards
c'est pas 500 milliards et qui plus est
c'est très inférieur aux chiffres
identiques proposée par l'allemagne
parce que l'allemagne aime se propose de
mettre 130 milliards sur la table pour
une économie qui a été en fait moins
touchés par l'accueil du coronavirus que
l'économie française alors jacques le
soutien justement à l'économie
ne se limite pas à ces mesures oui tout
à fait il faut savoir que dans le
soutien il ya d'abord le coût du chômage
partiel qui est très largement payés par
l'état
il y a le soutien aux pme et il y as
enfin le soutien aux collectivités
locales
là encore on arrive à peu de choses près
à 43 milliards c'est quelque chose qui
est important sauf que il faut savoir
qu'une partie de cet argent a déjà été
dépensée par exemple pour le chômage
partiel et que donc ce n'est pas de
l'argent que l'on peut assimiler à un
plan de relance alors ça qu'à vous avez
aussi parlé du manque à gagner pour
l'état engendrée par la crise économique
à combien sont ils oui effectivement
c'est fini il ya un véritable problème
de manque à gagner alors on le voit ce
manque à gagner il va toucher différents
impôts évidemment beaucoup touché
l'impôt sur les sociétés et on aboutit
il a un manque à gagner 2 66 milliards
auxquels il faut ajouter
et ça ne figure pas dans le tableau il
faut ajouter effectivement 4 milliards
qui correspondent à différentes
exemption d'impôt voire des pertes qui
touchent des recettes non fiscales de
l'état
nous arrivons à 70 milliards alors oui
c'est important mais cet argent
ce n'est pas de l'argent frais pour les
entreprises donc c'est 70 milliards là
encore il ne faut pas les compter dans
des mesures de soutien pour l'activité
économique
alors jacques cave combien maintenant
sellem le coût pour le budget de la
crise ducobu de 19 et de ses
conséquences économiques
alors pour l'instant d'après toujours le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
le coût total c'est 157 milliards même
dire 160 milliards avec la dérive qu'il
y aura sur le financement du chômage
partiel
on est donc très loin des 500 milliards
qui ont été annoncées ces 160 milliards
ça correspond à 6 5% du pib pour 2010 9
par rapport au pib estimé
de 2020 ça correspondrait à 7,2 pour
cent je rappelle qu emmanuel macron a
parlé d'un engagement de soutien de
l'ordre de 20% du pib
trenet de manière tout à fait évidente
on n'y est pas jacquat comment emmanuel
macron dont qu'arrive-t-il à cette
fameuse somme de 500 milliards d'euros
et bien parce qu'ils ajoutent aux
dépenses que va faire l'état ou au cou
qui sera supporté par le budget des
promesses de prêts et qu'ils sont faits
aux entreprises alors évidemment les
prêts ils doivent être remboursés c'est
pour ça qu'on ne peut pas les compter
de la même manière dans le solde
budgétaire et donc il faut rappeler que
sur ces prêts il a parlé grosso modo 2
300 milliards alors effectivement 300
milliards le 160 milliards on s'approche
des 500 milliards sauf que là encore si
on regarde l'argent frais qui est
apportée que ce soit aux entreprises ou
par exemple aux collectivités locales ou
encore aux très petites entreprises
on est plutôt autour de 87 milliards et
87 milliards faut faire attention c'est
un sixième pratiquement des 500
milliards dont on le voit il y a une
très grosse différence alors dont 87
milliards et non 500 milles ou jacques
c'est quand même une différence
considérable vous signaler également un
problème du même ordre avec les
promesses cette fois de l'union
européenne
oui tout à fait dans la manière dont
emmanuel macron à pro a je dirais a
présenté ses promesses
il a confondu plusieurs choses tout
d'abord il ya effectivement la
proposition franco-allemande qui portait
sur 1500 milliards d'euros et c'est une
proposition
après il y a la proposition faite par la
commission européenne en est déjà un peu
plus sérieux 750 milliards d'euros sauf
que cette proposition n'est toujours pas
votée et on sait qu'il y à un certain
nombre de pays qui s'opposent à ce type
de montrent en particulier ce qu'on
appelle les quatre frugaux 1 l'autriche
les pays-bas la suède le danemark
alors où en est on il ya en termes de
subventions pure on en est pour
l'instant plutôt de l'ordre de 310
milliards
ok
elle est évidemment la commission se
propose d'inclure des subventions qui
ont déjà été d'une certaine manière mise
au budget pour 55 milliards voilà on va
pas chipoter on arrive
grosso modo à 365 milliards et le reste
ça devrait être là encore des prêts
faits aux entreprises ce qui est
important c'est que actuellement ce sur
quoi travaille la commission de
bruxelles
c'est plutôt de 560 à 615 milliards
suivant ce que l'on introduit là dedans
on n'est même pas au niveau des 750
milliards et donc on voit bien il y as
loin de la coupe aux lèvres
dans ce cas dit emmanuel macron à l'orge
action vous comprends bien pour vous un
emmanuel macron c'est un petit peu trop
avancé dans sa dernière allocution
oui mais si vous voulez c'est fini il
faut pas non plus être dupe il est
évident qu emmanuel macron fait de la
politique il est tout à fait évident
qu'il cherche à présenter de manière je
dirais intéressante pour ses futurs
électeurs
l'action du gouvernement quitte là
encore à ne pas correspondre tout à fait
avec la réalité
il est aussi je dirais de son intérêt
politique de montrer que la commission
européenne et que l'union européenne a
réagi avec beaucoup de complétude et
beaucoup d'efficacité affecté ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas et on le voit
très bien au niveau des sommes qui sont
proposés mais d'un autre côté il est
peut être aussi de l'intérêt des
français de connaître les véritables
chiffres les chiffres qui sont indiqués
en particulier dans les deux dans les
documents de la commission européenne ou
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative merci jacques voilà qui
al'avantage d'être clair et qu'il va
nous faire évidemment réfléchir merci à
vous